when spring cleaning is underway who are
you going to call the junk man or Min I
should say let's welcome president Lou
Pavel chick and general manager comma
Burch of junk man the sponsors of this
segment welcome to the show well thank
you it's nice to be here good to have
you guys here now where were you last
week when I was trying to clean out my
condo no I think he was out tearing
something down okay so you you handle
junk and you handle
demos so tell us about that uh we offer
a lot of demo services for the Vegas
Valley we do anywhere from uh houses to
commercial buildings
we do pools driveways whatever you need
we'll deal with okay okay and what
difference or what makes the difference
between you know you guys from other
junk men in the community
we're a family-owned business okay we
love that
um you're not going to get a phone tree
when you call us you're going to talk to
a real person all right all right and I
think we have excellent customer service
and fair pricing okay we love to hear
that now let's talk about we talked
about demoing now let's talk about junk
because we're spring cleaning our homes
are full of things we should probably go
ahead and get rid of so what do you guys
do when we need when we need your help
well we offer two types of service we
have the full service junk removal where
we send a crew of two guys out okay do
all the loading of the truck and then we
also rent four 10 and 15 cubic yard bins
for the customers that like to do it
themselves okay that's good let's go get
them involved get them involved what
should they be prepared for what should
they have prepared if you guys are
coming to their home well all they have
to do is point to what they want removed
okay our guys will take it put it on the
truck and then we'll haul it off for
them all right now is there any job that
is too big or too small for the junk man
no yeah
yeah we'll take care of whatever you
guys needs like uh like I said any big
commercial buildings any no big no small
we'll take care of it just just give us
a call yeah because I think you had that
a small shed that needed to be demoed
one time we came out there to remove the
shirt simple job right and then we would
add a commercial building that we
demolished that that was like a
week-long project for you yeah now there
are people who need you guys to come
help them get rid of junk and there are
also people who want to be junk men
how can we do that well we're always
looking for good people if you've got a
great work ethic you don't want to be
confined by four walls for eight hours a
day give us a call
um You can call me at
702-527-5865 be happy to talk to you and
hopefully welcome you aboard to our team
all right well like I said it's spring
cleaning but this is a service we need
all year round so thank you guys for
your service and you guys can give them
a call at that number he just gave us or
visit them at their website at
vegasjunkman.com and don't forget this
special offer 10 off for military and
seniors that's great thank you guys oh
you're welcome thank you for having